Passengers are requested to stay
behind the colored line on the platform. Children,
you must have heard this announcement at some time or the other,
whenever you have gone to the platform or to
catch the train. Now let us
understand the physics behind it.  If we try
then what happens is that whenever a
fast moving train
passes near a platform, the air molecules in front of it
also get the same speed.
Now Bernoulli's theorem says something
like this that where  Where the velocity of
air will be very high, the pressure will be
reduced and where the velocity is
very low, the pressure will be high. So
here, if you are standing very close to a fast moving train,
then the pressure on your back side will be
very high.  And on your
front side, where the train is going to pass, the
pressure will reduce a lot and
hence a force can be exerted on you towards
the train, which
is also very dangerous.